for years people have been asking
Facebook for a dislike button Facebook
isn't going to give us that anytime soon
but they did just give us these gasps
Facebook calls them reactions six little
responses in animated emoji form the
like button you know now it's even more
thumbs up but now we also have love for
when the like button just doesn't cut it
sick of typing lol here's haha this is
Wow
and its meaning is probably the most
ambiguous of the bunch a little closer
to the dislike button you're sad
somebody give this little guy a hug then
just in time for election season
here's angry perfect for wordlessly
arguing politics with your crazy uncle
you can use reactions on desktop but
where they really shine is mobile
Facebook one of these to be quick just
press and hold the old like button and
choose how you're feeling where's the
final button